oh
my God
Champs is back watch your favorite
streamers find brilliancies stalemates
and of course blunders
let's take a look back at some of the
most hilarious moments from pogjance 10.
Mr Beast versus moist critical oh I
didn't even realize they started
they started and Charlie busts out the
uh the Dutch
the Dutch defense by Charlie and wait a
second had to be removed
this doesn't work yes he has yes he has
the entire King side development
those squares are moved with red have
you noticed Jimmy is making actual moves
have you seen
wow he lets his eyes move the pressure
in my hands
that's epic the future in my hands nine
Cinderella versus scissors the the check
king of the king and the queen queen of
six right
along with you Danny not me I said don't
play Queen F6
oh my gosh oh my God
eight rain Wilson versus Michelle carre
if well
thanks and you can't take back yeah
no
oh
but a butthole
seven Ludwig click the Subscribe button
see if it says subscribe free and purple
and if it does you're golden Ponyboy
anyway let's check on who's priming
right now
oh [__] it's my friend
[Music]
um
Willis
hey Willis can't wait to grab lunch
later catch you on the flippity flip
anyway back to the chess content you
guys have a good one
six Ludwig vs box
what what was that
he's trying to no don't pre-move that
that is over
oh my God you can actually steal me oh
this is a really really bad
do not do that because what is happening
you can accidentally stalemate if you do
this the king might go the other way
buddy
oh oh my God
oh no never mind no box no no it's gonna
be a stalemate it's gonna be a stalemate
[__] yeah I'll move like a staircase
yes five
there's versus xqc
[Music]
this is a very sad story
oh my God
there's no way here
oh my God why am I trying to get all
this part I swear I was just about to
say it and it happened so fast oh my God
four Mr Beast versus moist critical King
V1 so again it's Charlie's moment
the rest of the pieces out oh my God
he is Charlie's going off the deep end
but frankly Jimmy's got 15 seconds
he hung the house oh it's done mate it's
not just hanging The Rook it's mate
oh can we cut the truck gotcha can we
cut the tree close call
Pikachu
no gifted Subs
[Music]
three Mr Beast versus Ludwig he'll
potentially be stalemate but no Ludwig
has no mercy literally 50 wait oh there
was increment I didn't realize there was
increment yes there's a two second
increment so three minutes plus two
second increment he has now collected a
lot of time went all the way up
come on
oh my God the tiebreaker yes yes two
Ludwig versus logic Rook takes Knight
and now Queen F2 Queen g2s just game
over like yeah and oh and he's Queen up
two oh no oh no oh no
Queen up two
oh no oh we missed it and now he's made
it because me Ludwig is a force made in
two I know she's made it what a throw
King E8 and then Queen C8 and there's
actually a staircase Checkmate oh man
logic through maybe seven is made
Seven they're three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
and our number one xqc versus moist
critical here because when you bring out
the bishop like this uh it can become
very vulnerable right away so I'm not
sure that I like the like the
variational approach here
no please don't
and it's too soon
it's too soon
he just lost
yes yes
exactly what we practice for
yes
you know when I said it'd be fun to see
a Checkmate in four earlier I was I was
joking it was fun it wasn't real
foreign
[Music]
we're listening to moist critical right
now
Daniel noraditski is a [__] prophet
he said immediately that xqc will likely
go with the scotch open and he did so I
had the counter play and he immediately
blundered
well that's got to be a world record
thanks for the fat 10 gift Subs Pikachu
mine is throbbing throbbing what is
xqc's chat saying right now
[Music]